now we all know that Mount Everest is
the highest mountain peak in the world
almost 8 850 meters above sea level
right and obviously like nearby the top
the level of oxygen is not as much as
you would expect now at sea level with
that being almost one third right but
despite these difficulties Mount Everest
has some becomes a sort of a tourist
attraction where there are many people
who attempt to climb this mountain year
on year right now Mount Everest faces
two major threats the first one is
overcrowded because of what I just
explained right so these people will
come and throw trash and what not here
and the second thing is climate change
because of global warming the
temperature will obviously lead to
Melting of the glaciers and this leads
to changes in the ecosystem so are there
any other threads that is supposed to
Everest if you are there comment down
below and subscribe to don't memorize